EVIDENCE OF CHINA HACKING ECWO
LINDELL IS NOTACKING DOWN.EL CNT
SUING.DREW G
.REEPORT. GUY.ter: MIKL, YES,
ED THE ELECTION,
DONALD TRUMPEAY WON AND LINDELL.
IN ALL THE
STATES.
>> AND THEY CHANGED THE VOTE
E STATAND YOU
>> I HAVE THE WHOLE -- ACTUAL .
T PL
SPY PIECE OFDELL H E SE TO AT
ELECTIASD AND THAT'S
ACINEN C
PE OFFICIALSCO
PERCENTE.
RELEASED HIS EVIDENCES LIKES,TI
NO
THESE IMAGES ARE JUST LY
TER DAACROOF OON
CHANSTORY,AYINW
REAL EVIDENCE WI BE
REVEALED AT A CYBE
STRE L
DIE THRO
ANASERRO PREVIEW, SIX DIFFERENT
>> YOU SENT THIS ON FR
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT IS THIS?S JUST ONE P1.N.
IN THEREL BE TIM
>> W THIS TO OURTS ST DOESN'T SY
SPECIFIC ACTIONS OF AN
RELATED OD IT.
THENOU AYBOTHINGHUH?
EXPERT.
>> KDN'T CONSULT JUSE SULTED NI
EXTREMELY RUDIMENTARY METADA
WITHOUT A PRO HACKED SWITCHEDH
MONIS VIDEOAND LISTS THEM OUTI
ING.
THEY ARE COUPS THAUSE PAPER
BALLOTD BYTEMS NOTCONNECTED TOT.
TKED ONE OF THETO CNN THERE
BY ANYONE.
>> YOUIFY 15 COUVOS WE CONTACTE
COUNTIES, RED AND BLUE.
AND WE COU
PERSON THAID THIS ISN
POSS STAKEN?
THINK.
>>
>> GOOD.
S -- THEY T YOU Y LET U DO FUL5D
DOT  COUNTY,
. NEARLY TWO
UNTY. IN HIS VIDEO AND HIS UIHE
TH IE R ONE MAIN REAN S NER CONO
>>EVADA?EVERNE TO THE TERNET ALH
R.
THA
MACHINES UNDER LOAND SEALED.ANT
EVERNGENT OK T
AU PAPER
BALLOTS TO T RTHE
COMPUTER AND IN
EXMATCH.
>> WE AUDITED THRET PRO --
>> WHAT WOYOU
E A DOCUMENTARY
THY OF BM
>> SAY THADNEN I.HHA C
LIN-IGAN ATE SENATEGATION
OUT IT DPPEN ANYWHERE.
NO EVIDENCE OF SYSTEMIC. THINK
HOW VOTES ARET
COLLECTED AND IN THIS
I DO.Y, YOU KNOWHAT?
T ON
TH GET
TABULATED, THEY CAN GET HACKED
AFTETHFACT, WHICE,
BECAUSE DOG TO
ANYWAY.LTR TWIN,
YOU DIDN'T DO ANO MATCH
THEM UP.
>> THEY WEUDINST THECHINE.
>> WEREN'T, NO THEY
WH THE COUNTOF- HETOT? HAVE
ANO.
O MATTER WHO SAYHER IT'S LOC ELI
JUDGES OR EVEN DONALD TRUMP'S
SAME.EY ARE WRONG.SE CS
LYING?
WROTE NO
Y ON  DON'T WHAT
>> H INFORMAE CEIMS HEPELI
WHO PROVES HIM WRONG. MIKE, YOU
ANYTHING.
CAN- U CA.
NO.
THIS IS ERRE
WE'RE VIT TO THE
PEOPLE THAT SHOW UP.
WE'RE GOING EM A
STATE.
GEA,APART.
OU COULDSIBLY BE THE
IM OF A SCAM HERE.
>> YOU COME TO THE
SYMPOSIUM AND MAKEMILLION.E WE .
OHYO
>> WORRI
OUE WORRIED THAT WHAT YOU ARE
DOY OR TELY D
I
ELECT OF THETED ND FOSTERING WU
BE -
>> DAM TO THIS COUNTRY.
>> ABOUT BIDENE DEMO NEVERNG.
>> THROUGH TS
INVESTIGATION --
>> NO YOU'RE NOT.U'RE LYING.>> N
NG. AIUS.
>>YO SAYING THAT -- BIDEN WA
ILLEGITIMATELYED?
>> I'M SAYING THHI P ACKN OUR CS
N.HAT'S RIGHT.
E WHO WATCHED YOUR
VIDEO BELIEVE WHAT YOUAY.
>> A HUNDRED PERCENT.
>> IF YOU'RE, ISN'T THAT
VERY DANGEROUS?
BUD IT OUT.
T MI
NSDO YOU HAVE ANRE T
BELITHS OFTHISAN, HE HASRED PRON
IS NO PROOF AND IT'S
DEBUNKED.
IT'S LIKE HIS SU
REMEDIES.
HISTORY.
AT JUST -- THTION,  TELL,
ANDERSON, GOES ROUND AND ROUND
I'M TELLING YOU AFTE
DISCUSSII'M NOE
LINDELL UNDERSTANDS HOW
RKER AT HES PROOF OF MASCONSPIR
SUOUES
VEE CES, NEVA OWS THEIR PROOF.TO
RECYCLEDTH
PAST,
SCD.